hello
woo it's live we did it make sure it's
working on twitch
it is success welcome friends
um hang on let me make sure
it sent out twitch notifications did it
send you a notification scooterman
gaming
i'm worried that it didn't since i
accidentally streamed copyrighted music
because of the game awards
hopefully it did um hello everyone today
i'm doing a stream that i'm very very
very excited about this is like
one of the most exciting things that i
think i've done all year i think this is
gonna be a really good time
um so what i'm doing is for
tiltify this is not sponsored it's just
something that i
you know wanted to do because i've been
working with them it's basically called
clause my cause and what i'm doing
is partnering with them to basically go
to smaller streamers who are currently
doing fundraising campaigns
going to their twitches and then just
like throwing money
on their campaigns so all of this is
money for charity not to the individual
streamers they have to be
someone who is currently uh streaming on
twitch using
these two hashtags is how we find them
basically um
i think it's gonna be a very good time
it didn't i've been shadow banned on
twitch again
that's not good for this of all streams
let me just tweet it out to to make sure
people get here before we go
send the first person some money um but
naturally worth mentioning
this is wait did it work
okay now it looks like people on twitter
here
it seems like it's worked now did you
guys get a notification twitch did it
did it just go through
okay you did okay okay maybe we have not
been shadow banned great news
so yes uh i feel like i need to disclose
this is not my money
i ain't got this kind of money um this
is
tiltify ultimately uh helping me give to
people and i am part of the tiltify
clause team um along with these really
wonderful people here so i'm really
excited to do this
hopefully we get some like really
excited
uh reactions um is the plan
so i think we already have someone to
start with
here we go this is twitch.tv
smurky put this in here
make sure it's not muted i am going to
get ads every time when i
consider that basically see people's
reactions
to uh donating to their campaigns
i'm really excited this stream will
probably be about an
hour okay here we go
make sure i can hear you buddy on me
there we go
i'm mute here
can i hear it is the question i
currently cannot it's muted here as well
there you go okay i don't think it's
actually 270 days that'd be weird
so this dude if i make myself toontown
gives to you a lot awaited update just
for you
has currently raised 358 dollars
for the past year of his two thousand
five hundred dollar goal i've been
on a bit of a vacation for my job as
editor of the blog what is he raising
the job
working over at jesse's joke repair
we've had tons to fix literally so this
is obviously
a reference to joey working at shell
games
he's raising money for evil gamers which
i love
it's still one of my favorite things how
did you know all right all right all
right let's do it okay
two contracts to an ounce get your hot
cocoa and you will
or trash buyers ready because we're
going to be celebrating 270 all right
um let's do it what's that shall we drop
some money on him
let's go let's do it um let's do it
2.7.0 update the update is the largest
one that seems
i'm really excited i think this is gonna
be dope with many long-awaited features
and fixes if he's not reading the whole
[Music]
time
[Music]
what
oh my gosh
that's just so good holy crap
is watching my stream hi
oh my god hi oh my oh my
god what um
i don't know what to say to to that
oh my gosh the best
hi hi hi elena hi okay but i'm
i'm honored hello wow
what two thousand dollars
oh my goodness
this is the best this is the absolute
best oh you're right i should show you
guys his chat hang on here we go
he doesn't have many viewers you guys
could go throw him some love in his chat
right now
here we go here we go hi elena
um thank you um thank you
thank you for donating two thousand
dollars to one up on cancer
one up on cancer financial assistance to
adults in the united states who
are undergoing cancer treatment and
to be able to provide that support
during the holiday season
oh man that really puts a smile on my
face
and now we're almost at our goal we're
now less than 150
away from like having to play a horror
game and i hate horror games oh no
i have to make him play a horror game oh
that's my bad we're streaming horror
games
i'm so sorry my friend daco that i would
stream five nights at freddy's
and uh yeah oh my god elena i don't know
if you're watching me right now but
thank you so much
um i appreciate it um
[Music]
wow i i i don't know what to say i don't
know what to say
um this is a good idea thank you so much
um for anyone following if you guys
don't know who i am
you damn right who the heck is this yeah
i just put the
his link in chat if you guys want to go
bum bought him with kindness
hold that thought silver for a werewolf
oh my god what is happening
[Music]
this is wonderful oh my gosh
hey silver fur thank you so much for the
subscription with prime gaming
oh my god i am i also feel like
goodness all these streamers are so much
better than me like look at hello
everyone
my name is smokey um i'm a college
student i just finished up
everything's so much cooler than what i
have
um i've been streaming on twitch since
like 2015 but i've been streaming since
2012.
like what is all of this like i don't
know twitch now enough
well enough to understand the
opportunity what is happening
tony thank you for the song oh my gosh
elena sent me hello nico oh my goodness
thank you all for the bit what is
happening this is incredible
this is incredible gosh thank you so
much
um wow
oh my goodness wow
he's really he's all out he got the
leroy
oh my god he's really got it done
he dance every time this is amazing
all these people with their good streams
oh my gosh
i mean i'm so sorry i everyone's ears
just died
that is true if you guys happen to want
to donate a little bit of money to him
he is almost
at his goal of 2 500. um he's really
what's going on um raising money for
cancer research
um i've been streaming for charity ever
since 2018.
um i streamed for st jude play live
and yeah um ever since i started
streaming for charity for st
jude uh we've raised over forty
thousand dollars for charities um ever
well ever since i started streaming in
2012
but really charity amazing an integral
part of this dude has
2018 currently 150 views and
is using his time to raise money for
charity what's that one cancer
thing that rolls so that absolutely
rules
oh my gosh um okay to the person who
just came in my youtube chat
with all these followers i literally say
something negative
shocked what's wrong with you what is
wrong with you
you see what we're doing right now elena
thank you get out of here
what is happening um i i wish i could
read everyone's chats drino thank you
for the 300 bits
thank you so much oh my goodness um
yeah i i
this i i've this is so much time it just
keeps happening
thank you david okay okay okay but at
some point we have to be on to someone
else so close to 2500. but that is the
part that's getting me is how close
[Music]
but we have contributed this moment oh
oh my gosh um
okay uh we've raised over five dollars
and i'm just a college student and it's
amazing that we can use platforms like
twitch to give back and
you know tiltify it's it's amazing i
i just the the fact that you the
that tiltify is doing this inspires me
to go out and
do stuff like this oh okay okay i have
to i have to stop there are other people
that i want to stop by
um obviously amazing i'm going to leave
the link in here again for you guys
there you go if you want to if you want
to stop by but yes for anyone who's just
joining us
i mean i guess i have been live for 10
minutes this is part of till five season
of giving so basically what i'm doing is
is going to people's streams and giving
them money on their charity streams
um which is
like genuinely one of the coolest
streams i've ever had the chance to be a
part of
uh genuinely just just the absolute best
so
let's jump to another streamer shall we
um here we go
let me make sure i don't screw up what
they're raising money for this time
all right all right all right we have
another one
every time i'm gonna get an ad
and it's always the same ad what are
they what is this for nine viewers
we i mean okay you guys don't go over
here yet until we've done
the thing and then you can go over there
and i will send you guys the link to
spam that chat okay
oh you're playing a game i love zarya in
the blind forest
oh and they have the uh they have
currently raised zero dollars it is for
mental healthcare america huge fan
absolutely huge fan
um so this is someone called gifted
faker
they currently have eight viewers i love
this game
light container it's a really nice
overlay too let me actually like
properly show you guys like
find more spirit like in here like
it's really pretty it's really nice and
then this is the
here we go we just dropped 500 on them
you gotta wait for it to notice though
come on
come on you'll see it any second now but
i will continue to watch you play ari in
the meantime for the record this one was
a hundred dollar goal
that we have just dropped 500 on
thus passing the goal and then let me
throw you guys over there here we go
get on it
she's noticed
let me get out of wait let me get out of
the
let me get out of this i'm pretty sure
she's noticed
she's done i'm sorry that was my fault
wait wait hold on
i'm gonna i'm crying cool
dude hold on
this is so good wait
i'm literally crying i feel like i need
a tutorial seriously
500.
hi
[Laughter]
wait is that what that really smells oh
my gosh
this is so nice i'm trying my best to
pull up the thing thank you for all of
the followers right now and i'm very
sorry for just instinctively crying
no i'm gonna cry because she's crying oh
no
oh my gosh
she's playing a really good game
i almost didn't i almost didn't dream
tonight
because i've had a very stressful week
and i almost didn't stream tonight but i
did because i wanted to push through the
anxieties that i were having
and i knew that this month i wanted to
raise money
for the i don't mind campaign because
i'm a firm believer and if you
speak more about about your own
anxieties and your stress and your
mental health issues that more people
can get help
and this is absolutely incredible
i know i'm crying because she's so sweet
doing my absolute best
oh my gosh just stop crying but that's
not that's not gonna happen
um uh
and we have my first ever hype train
happening
um i have honestly no idea how i hate
crane works
i don't need that to be fair i don't
need this to be fair i have no idea
thank you oh my gosh you are a huge
inspiration for me as a content creator
thank you person in this industry uh i
will change
lights in a second i can see that you
have asked uh i probably will not be
able to see what color you have
requested as
the chat keeps showing who uh is now
following and
gifting subs and uh sharing emotes
and everything uh you're raising money
for something this is the best
yeah you guys are helping to make this
the best to be clear i can't turn her
volume up any louder i'm sorry you guys
uh a huge thing for me
i i like this is all you guys this isn't
me
this is all you you guys doing that
thank you for all of the gift subs and
for for everything
i uh
i will get back to playing the game
image brief second um
i would also like to just point out uh
if anyone ever feels like they are
uh alone in the way your mind works and
the way i try and turn her up personally
and the way that you you
uh you might not think
right you're not
there are so many other people out in
this world
who think like you and have the same
not so good stuff sometimes that maybe
help me early you're not alone
thank you thank you for the bits
you are not alone there are so many
people out there
and if more people talked about what
goes on in their heads
she's right then all of it's right she's
100 right
i hope more people would be able to get
help
uh so thank you
i think the tears have uh
uh i'm still like shaking this is
amazing
thank you that's okay hey
anytime you all are welcome to stick
around and watch
while we're playing some more ori in the
blindfold he's a really good guy
i will give the hugest preface of i am a
terrible platformer
um gamer as far as oh who asked the
street is his name here you go
uh i can't write in a chat because i'm
not logged in because this i'm doing
this
incognito window so i can't say anything
to her sadly
so you guys can do that for me and i
will do my best
right now to uh stop shaking
as i am literally shaking um
the best truly the best okay i need to i
want to just tweet out that i'm live
right now thank you i'm also sorry if uh
streamlabs is called hydrate issue
uh
alana says i'm the best
[Laughter]
hi thank you hey but my chat is is
pretty much just screen webs at this
point i will christian
i'll check this water in a minute um
hi hello alana hi
thank you yeah you're welcome thank you
so much i barely did anything i
i wow okay
i'm shaking 600 i
i know it's 500 i can read i'm really
good at reading
575 right now
okay i tweeted the thing did not
think i would raise we have another one
for something that means so much to me
i have to feel myself just shaking
no no i can't talk the
okay okay i could watch them forever
this is incredible uh she's playing a
great game or
absolutely rules let's jump over here
too
ah you ever punch your microphone it's
all right i can handle something for
mature audiences
taco bell's nachos party pack that every
time every time it's fine
it's fine
okay oh my god this sucks
how much are you trying to raise two
hundred dollars we could probably do
that
also i'm happy to just watch you play
this game
hold up are you doing proximity chat or
just discord yes
oh my god oh no oh it's for thanks miss
i'm raising money for that this weekend
uh on friday would anyone like to come
fix likes
no no i never watch other people play
among us
you know uh
thank miss is a red nose day stream that
jacksepticeye put together for the
record
i think they've ordered raised like two
million dollars like an insane amount of
money
um but there is always more where that
came from
don't worry you got away i don't trust
that i think we've sent it
there we go where the [ __ ] are you guys
are those just literally just haunting
me we donated a thousand dollars
what are we supposed to do come on
oh let me link you guys hang on hang on
the waiting for them to notice is the
funniest thing i think it's so cute
what game mode are they playing i'm
confused like all the tasks are done
by the way ghost if you haven't done
your test do your task don't
stop stuff is happening my chat i don't
know what it is because i don't
i don't want to die
[Laughter]
i got a raid oh [ __ ] okay well
hang on guys
[Laughter]
i'm trying not to die this is gonna be
amazing oh [ __ ]
now we're
hold on i don't even care if near i
don't even care if i die at this point
what is happening
holy crap what happened this one's cool
because it's like multiple people what's
happening
look whoever is rating me right now
thank you so much who is this
i don't even care right now i gotta
figure out what's going on everything's
going crazy and i don't know what's
happening
i'm getting follows and bits thank you
guys so much what is happening
out of respect maybe do not kill matt
holy crap i'm not gonna do it until they
get back
this is the coolest i feel like i have
so much positive power
[Laughter]
i'm like i'm like literally crying
who raided me i didn't even technically
raid you
okay let's hang out let's if you want to
go you want to jump in here again
who who rated me thank you so much to
whoever did that
i am missing something here and i i
don't know what to say
[Laughter]
there's a hype train going on
no they still haven't died though do you
see who rated you with those messages
i have no idea who raided me so much is
happening
yeah oh [ __ ] dude
you went really fast oh my god you guys
oh my god
[Music]
this is incredible thank you so much i
got you
oh my god over a thousand dollars
donated oh yeah i love you i love all of
you so much
oh that's amazing and i like how they
just saw this dead body with the report
button the whole time as well
[Laughter]
an employee what employee from what
200 209
i love that you can hear everyone react
to it
congratulations i don't
oh my god
there's a lot of money for your next
videos you guys make
oh my god are you gonna get killed
well i don't want to be responsible for
that
[Music]
try to figure it out this
[Music]
oh they said not to kill her oh that's
the best
like you guys oh my god i'm losing my
mind right now this being a multiplayer
game is extra fun
[Laughter]
oh my god you guys thank you guys so
amazing
amazing even right now you love to see
it oh man
okay okay
but i do have another person to drop
money on all right all right all right
incredible okay okay okay let's keep
going let's keep going
we got more people to spread love to you
know what i'm saying it's gonna give me
an ad again
amazon got to get that money you only
got seven viewers right now
we got some work to do
okay what are you playing oh dead by
daylight oh well that's going to be this
is going to be wild
you're playing dead by daylight then
this is going to happen so this person
is raising money for
marine toys for tots and
they have raised 346 dollars of 500
dead by daylight is very intense
we could really screw this game up yes
sorry let me give you guys the link here
you go
there you go yo hawks what's going on
dude how you doing brother
whoa we made it we got it
get those swords this is gonna be this
one's gonna be fun this is a high-energy
gentleman
what okay hello oh
what hello
uh the raid is starting
oh my oh my god
[Laughter]
my cheeks hurt from smiling so much
breaking no oh my
a lot of dude what's going on
oh this is this is something
this is something right here whoever
this raid is thank you for the raid
oh my a lot
[Music]
gonna be giving love like that seriously
[Laughter]
is
[Music]
[Music]
oh my gosh actually
i'm not a mistake for the 25
oh he's based on a typhlosion that's
like me being a charlanazon
i knew we could do it but i wasn't
expecting to get close
i wasn't oh yeah he's using the hashtags
by the way this is how in part how we're
finding people
oh my god no we even started a hype
train
yeah i know i'm right oh his voice
that's so funny
okay but i'm thinking that we need to do
this the other way around chet
oh my god thank you all so much we need
to do this the other way around i need
to donate
and then you guys go right thank you
okay
because i think that like then we're
getting the wrong you know what i'm
saying
yeah so i donate and then you guys roll
through
so i'll give you guys the link once i've
done the donation
got it i think that makes more sense
because then they like so then they're
excited from the donation and then from
you get it yeah i appreciate it if we
could agree that's brilliant
okay wow
oh my god this voice is so good
oh my god i just oh this is the best
this is so good thank you tiltify
this is so good what just happened you
just got to go make people really happy
like this is the best thing ever oh my
gosh
okay okay okay we have another one we
have another one
you guys aren't jumping in until
donations gone through
all right
guys don't even understand i
i had a uh a hopeful apollo goal of
1750 you guys just broke that
you guys just absolutely broke that
thank you all so much for the love and
knowledge with another five dollars
thank
that's we are nine hundred one dollars
right now
we're oh my oh my goodness
so good okay okay okay i can i can
genuinely watch one person forever this
is
uh all right next one nobody read yet
because not yet because i never expected
me first the numbers
right um prescription men i didn't find
out until everyone called it okay
okay we're making it happen with us
mathism see
light and i was like wait not everyone
sees the light in the lines like that
she's australian what oh my gosh she's
totally confused
and she's raising money for oh australia
um i'm not a genealogist if you guys
didn't already know
um
okay okay let me let me drop you guys
here we go here we go here we go
she hasn't said anything
in complete shock
i was gonna say the australian wildlife
got really really screwed
um by the fires i'm so taken aback right
now i'm
so sorry
i'm so sorry i'm so sorry do you don't
apologize
a lot of peace and did i see your name
work it's just like all the
notifications god
thank you so much
it's just really good eyeliner how'd she
do that though oh my god
you just came up with the claws
thank you so i'm gonna cry thank you so
much
oh my gosh
oh my god that's so much
money oh my goodness hello everyone i'm
so sorry i'm so like
the fact that she's apologizing is so
sweet
thank you why are you apologizing you
angel
without a thousand dollars
[Music]
[Music]
oh my gosh i don't know what this means
a 100 hype train i don't know what that
means
i think that's good we do good you guys
so much for the bitties as well i see
them
thank you and thank you for all the
followers yo look there's more
jugs me mcducks and drake with donations
as well
thank you so much doing our part you
guys are so
sweet seriously all the hugs
she didn't say anything for like a good
two minutes
she was like dead silent for a really
long time i need to grab a tissue
oh my goodness thank you so much for
helping support these
beautiful beautiful creatures i love
them anytime oh my goodness
anytime thank you i need a brain tumor
thank you everybody who's
what
we just had 11 000 followers as well
oh my goodness i don't even know what's
going on just thank you let me grab some
water
everybody stay hydrated i just want to
thank you all everyone for 20
thank you so much but you are
contributing to this okay you guys are
all contributing to this too and it's
the best
oh my goodness guys i'm so sorry i'm
just like all over the place
i'm so so sorry i apologize i hope
hello everyone i hope that you're all
doing well
i'm so sorry i'm just so i don't even
know
i'm so if she you're fabulous and i love
you
you're incredible oh my gosh oh my god
how do you get your eyeliner like that
though well
everybody who's donated thank you
i don't have wings like that kind
donation always see that e
wheel mods if i've missed any um
redemptions like ooh and stuff just let
me know you
understand how twitch works thank you so
much i'm gonna do today because you're
the first ever streamer
to use live captions that's freaking
that is awesome that she's using
i should do that for the koalas oh my
goodness you guys are seriously so sweet
thank you so much
alana wants to know how you do your
island i'm staying for that
i've been doing my eyeliner ever since i
was 12 because people
same used to call me ugly so
i just used to do my eyeliner it's so
good are you kidding me that used to
give me the most confidence back i do
not know how to do that i'm doing them
for a very long time
um but i don't know it's hard for me to
explain not in a million years couldn't
do it just
couldn't do it and then i draw it down
insane kind of fill it in
like i get the i get the flick first and
then i throw it across
i'll try that's kind of how i do it i'll
try all right we got the answer we
wanted
okay well i could stay forever people at
school were mean
i'm not gonna mess with the ten dollars
as wolf jumping into the next one
you guys are waiting remember you guys
are waiting okay
you are waiting until
i donate the thing and then you'll jump
with me
okay everybody agrees okay is this still
an ad technically yes okay
they get sneaky with those ads i don't
know which one is which
okay
oh they're playing phasmaphobia oh this
could get this could get hectic
this could get intense on master viper
21
thank you for the follow-up welcome on
it all right they've raised those
numbers
and that's healthcare for the homeless
great content amazing community
absolutely love it
this is actually pretty good time to do
it because welcome to a tech squad you
my plus one yeah boy mg thank you for
the follow wow that was cool oh i'm
covering this
satisfied i gotta make that cut
[Music]
look at these people's cool streets
guaranteed if you know what i mean
these people are all so much cooler than
me
okay thank you i appreciate your you
bring your people over everybody welcome
on in
if you guys are new coming to the stream
uh today people come to your stream but
it is day five of mine
wait till he notices first and then i'll
drop it for you okay oh
yeah son welcome to a tech squad you're
my plus
[Music]
one
wait
what oh yeah son
welcome to a tech squad you're my plus
one
that's gonna happen a lot
again so much silence
oh yeah son welcome to a test
what happens
what what is happening right now
[Laughter]
it's going to happen a lot buddy wait
wait wait wait
i'll give my plus one
what is this oh my gosh
what is actually happening right now
dude does not know what's happening
incredible i don't think he's addressed
the donation
it did come up though i played music you
[ __ ] idiot
oh my gosh
yeah son welcome to it what is happening
plus one
i think he seems suspicious
yeah son welcome to a tech squad you're
my plus
you think it's complete shock nasty
[ __ ]
i'm so confused happy holidays
yes hype train crap is getting wild in
here oh
yes i am 100 squad
so confusing i don't understand what's
so confusing
[Laughter]
i am confused i don't know how to
explain it what are we telling welcome
to a tech squad you're my plus one
loving the statue stream can we um
somebody what just tell him uh
this is happening right now welcome to
someone came in uh
i don't know how to explain what's
happening oh
bitties i
oh do we just kind of not maybe did the
stream break oh
no yeah
i am
oh yeah son i don't know how to
explain it um okay okay okay
i mean he has a lot of sound alerts but
it's because he doesn't normally have
just
you and donated one thousand dollars
perfect
there you go that's perfect did you hear
that welcome
[Music]
very nice very nice
squad
he's so confused yeah son
welcome to a tech squad you're my plus
one
okay i want to stay around till he
figures it out but i also feel like
you think he thinks he's being pranked i
hope not welcome to a tech squad
don't want him to feel like like i put
him on display or something who doesn't
feel bad about it
oh yes he's very confused okay okay okay
it's fine
it's fine he'll figure it out he'll
figure it out and i hope we haven't have
uh bonded him by accident though okay
okay
i love that it's either what welcome to
who is alana
oh what is happening that's incredible
what is actually [ __ ] happening
okay okay okay yes let's go to the good
exo welcome
squad plus [ __ ] lost
grab taco gosh i think that's my
favorite reaction yet
stop just abs stop it stop it okay
nobody got here yet
you know the rules i'm not doing it yet
you wait until we donate gotcha
okay distribute oh does that be that bad
she's building i'm hearing anywhere from
like 14 to 16 inches and i was like what
i'm like what i didn't realize we were
supposed to get that
she's raising money for
[Music]
your boy children research hospital
welcome to the sushi factory right here
how cool is it
which we love we love to see that
why are you under my tree there's a dog
that's a dog
you guys it's a dog okay nobody nobody
come in yet
hey hey whoever said that tom you
weren't supposed to do that yet we
haven't donated the buddy yet she's
trying to raise two thousand dollars
hi tom how are you tom uh white
christmas is coming lol i mean
we you know one would prefer a white
christmas right
away write down sushi guys i hope
nothing epic
epic happens i mean obviously
we hope that something has something
something
decent like nothing serious happens
you don't there we go nobody she didn't
know
right you guys all came in here and
yelled about tom what happened
hello
what what just happened did something
happen i'm confused
[Laughter]
[Music]
what is going on
[Music]
sushi
[Music]
hello
she's just trying to build a desk you
know just out here trying to build her
desk
[Music]
i like a song though
[Music]
about this is that's a real person this
is a real person who's just having this
night
you know followers
[Music]
i can't right now oh my god i was not
expecting something like the sense of
building my desk
oh my goodness
oh i'm trying to i know hold on guys
give me a second
my alerts are growing crazy
[Music]
the happiness is so nice
oh my god hi hold on
let me get in my thing i wasn't prepared
i think she's trying to check the
donation which i respect
oh my god no no
you guys did not
no he's just hanging out
building a desk the last guy just saw
the donation no way that's so funny
is it is it pronounced atlanta
is it pronounced atlanta pronounced
[Music]
[Music]
donation thank you so much
[Music]
[Music]
i'm sorry for the alert it's me singing
i'm just kidding
it's brilliant don't get rid of it i
like it thank you guys it's so good
donations thank you
alana pierce my dear for the 12
290 donation
and jugs for the 25 anonymous for the
1jtv for the 20 and dusty mints for the
ten dollars
this is the best absolute best
i can't even keep up i'm gonna say thank
you for the bitties because i feel like
there's bitties in there oh my god guys
thank you for all the followers
[Music]
thank you so much so
[Music]
thank you for the gifts and subs and all
the videos guys
it's
[Music]
good luck with the desk though hold on
guys i'll bring the dog out
[Music]
[Music]
i'm sorry this is my dog shinji oh
[Applause]
[Music]
the literal opposite oh my god means so
much to me
[Music]
i really really appreciate it i wasn't
sure if i was gonna hit my
my goal for this month because i've had
a lot of mental stuff going on and still
raising money for st
jude it really means so much thank you
thank you so much for the donations guys
i can't thank you guys enough um
thank you so much people are incredible
they're all like i'm studying or you
know i'm having a tough month and i did
it anyway and they're still raising
money for charities
also oh my gosh
thank you guys i can't say you thank you
enough for all the follows and bitties
and again thank you so much for the
donations you're amazing you're amazing
i really appreciate it guys
it means so much because um
i hope you guys could hear me pass all
this
i'm not i was not ready for this
okay okay i have to keep moving i could
say that forever your daughter to cancer
well i caught leave you 2018 so this
charity means the world to me
so thank you so much for doing this
um yeah she was like a daughter to me
so to to have this donation for the kids
really means a lot thank you so thank
you so much
elena again for the donation and for
for you don't know for the class
clause my cause event it really means a
lot
let's save some people from cancer yes
guys thank you so much for the donors
thank you for everything
oh i can't even
you're welcome you're amazing you know i
do it in her name and it really means
the world so this is how i keep her
memory alive
um this is how i keep eliana's memory
alive
oh my god guys thank you so much for the
donors
uh shy thank you for the ten dollars
anonymous for the five
and again robin these people are doing
this in their spare time
like
not that i don't also do that i guess
but like
i don't know incredible okay you're not
tom don't blow this again okay
guru figured it out i'm proud of him
okay okay okay
nobody ruined this nobody ruined this
okay i know this thing is faster
you you stay out of here until we're
ready
all right rude of fish should be able to
handle it's just there's a huge level
deficit here oh it's enough that's the
thing i'm worried about what's he
raising money i think he can
run cross to be fair i think he can tank
and he's got
a 700 goal all right cool [ __ ] i think
we can make that work
i'm so mad yeah boy mg thank you for the
follow today i appreciate it buddy thank
you so much thank you
thank you all right we trade paralysis i
do love watching that's actually pretty
good
that puts me in the lead right they're
very excited the attack's gonna kind of
ah wow wow holy [ __ ] maybe i'm fine here
dude
stop following who came in here and
yelled alana
don't do it yet stop stop oh my god oh
hi everybody
you guys stalled stop it dead honest if
i'm gonna be completely real with you i
was like oh is this just
another thing of follow bots okay all
right
tom vanessa hawks thank you so much for
the pause i appreciate it
i can't follow the day because i have to
put it into the browser are you guys
doing i hope you're all well
i don't have to hide it from saying hey
i'm fine before the battle's over what
is happening
what is that what is occurring what a
lot of wait whoa
wait wait hold on wait a god damn second
hold on wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait now you guys suck though
just go for it
hello the rain is the not important part
thousand dollar don't
there we go there we go do we do we need
to have a hot
okay i'm right all right
guys welcome on in everybody hello
i hope you're all incredible if you
don't know who i am that
makes sense my name is brandon right now
we're doing a
pokemon emerald um
good choices randomizer my brain is
shutting off right now randomizer
nuzlocke
i'm getting absolutely obliterated i
hope you're all incredible hi literally
everybody and
anybody what you guys doing
hey okay all right i literally can't
make out what's happening
i saw i saw a series of bits thank for
the bits guys i appreciate it thank you
so much
congrats man thank you i don't know
what's occurring
dead honest i don't know what's
happening what's occurring it's such a
sweet way to say that all right i'm
gonna have to get more sneaky with
hiding it because you guys are ruining
it thank you so much everybody
i love your voice i love your face i see
your faces is the problem
oh my god guys hello i hope you're all
incredible
allah says hi hi alana i hope you're
incredible thank you so much for the
thousand dollar don't know that was nuts
of you thank you so much
it was super nice of you thank you thank
you thank you thank you thank you thank
you
man i'm gonna be dead honest was not
expecting this
so so now i'm just sort of here
it seems good okay okay
oh my god what is happening i did you
but i don't what actually is occurring
right now what is occurring
what the [ __ ] i think this dude rules yo
bro i'm gonna start watching your stream
you're too positive for this earth
no you how you doing wrath i hope you're
incredible nice man congrats for
your charity thank you so much flash i
appreciate it buddy oh my god i can
finally
slowly start to read some of this
classes hi hi alana thank you so much
thank you [ __ ] support that's super
nice without anyone that's much really
really
charity we're raising money for the
american red cross we are currently
now at a thousand six hundred and
sixty-seven
sorry my brain's turning up i mean let
me slow down a bit we are currently at
one thousand six hundred and seventy two
dollars raised at the moment
and i still don't know it's occurring
thank you so much for all the support
just two girls that was this dude
quite incredible okay thank you so much
it's still joking
let's go and i think i will have it
hidden successfully this time
i do okay i don't think you guys will
figure it out
hopefully he's raising i don't know what
game to switch to
hope for the day christmas of giving
and he's on his face i don't have to
worry about it okay
is this persona music
here we go there we go
what what
oh
[Music]
holy [ __ ] here we go
[Music]
oh my god i can't even speak right now
thank you so much
this means a lot okay let let me
let me mute this so i can oh my god
soda please is it kim because of amyloid
music
what music was that did he say dota i
recognize
whatever is christ i want to thank my
mom my dad
i want to thank my mom
i want to thank my mom my dad
[Music]
i want to thank my mom thank you
everyone
that's following and thank you to alana
and everyone who's
who's donated and who's given bits and i
think
i saw someone subscribing too it's going
so fast that i'm
i'm i don't know what's happening right
now so
um i wanna thank my mom
um this is the best
this is just the absolute best he didn't
have anything on the screen before we
came through
and now look at it um okay
so i think i should mute my um
alerts right now
um so i'm gonna mute my alerts real
quick and then i wanna talk about why
i chose this charity yeah because this
is a cherry that's very close to me
that sounds great i love that over 10
times as much oh my god
means a lot so
holy wow okay
so um like
i even have a shirt have hope that's um
also supporting hope for the day
um don't mute okay
[Laughter]
um alana wants to know the game you're
playing oh
uh let me jesus christ go fix that
um it's dota underlords hell yeah
music good music okay okay i have a lot
more that i can get through so we're
gonna have to start moving faster which
does suck
a little bit because i don't want to
skip through it i would like to hear
why specifically the charity is
important because that's the ones that
gets my heart
um stop stressing about stop demanding
so sorry i i'm so flabbergasted right
now so
i'm gonna tell my story yes um
[Music]
so hope for the day is a charity that's
um
doing uh active suicide prevention
and um
[Music]
um i i've had a long history of mental
health
issues and um in 2017 i even
had a suicide attempt um
but right now i'm feeling
so much better and i wanted to do
what um what i could
to try and help this charity um
[Music]
which is doing something that i really
believe in
[Music]
um and humans can be really nice
sometimes
you know like i can't stress enough how
much
suicide has affected my life like a lot
of people
i know personally have been suicidal and
have gotten the help they needed
and sadly some of the people i know
haven't made it through those
issues they had
and um
i just made myself sad so yeah um
i i chose this charity because of those
reasons suicide has
this is the smallest dreamer
a part of my life no matter how much i
don't want it to be part of my life
people can be really nice issues so
hope for the day i feel is a charity
um that really does something that is
needed
um right now
and i just can't help str
i just can't stress enough um
how much
this means to me and to so many people
that
um
that um are going through all of this
um yes tom
and jack tom get out of here
uh yes friend wait so i'm picking
streamers
i'm still i'm still like flabbergasted
and passed away from suicide and it's
important to be open about mental health
yeah i i couldn't agree more oh
no suicide is
such this one um like
i i'm i'm born and raised in greenland
where the suicide rate is one of the
highest in the world if not the highest
and um
and um so i i know a lot of people
um who have been affected by suicide in
one way or another
and i just want to thank everyone for
the follows and
for going so much above my goal
and um
i could watch these people forever it's
really hard to swap it's so nice
i'm sorry i i'm still shaking
[Laughter]
incredible okay okay okay okay we have
another one
and uh it's hard to leave
is the problem i'm having
okay seven viewers i know that you guys
could technically read the title but
don't be a joke
don't be a joke okay that's all i'm
saying
and healthier uh just habits in general
i'm not as good as i should be i need to
start like stretching
out lgbt food i'll get there eventually
currently has three hundred dollars
raised of five hundred dollars
oh she's sewing i what i also love about
this is like the amount of variety of
of things people are streaming is really
cool
oh my back sometimes your back hurts
when you're sick
so that's the good things that happen
yeah boy
mg thank you so much for the follow-up i
really appreciate your support stop it
build healthier habits on eating
healthier
uh workouts there shouldn't be 20 of you
guys stop
oh my gosh stop uh what is this one
demeter be cool thank you so much for
the follow thank you as well first
because they'll see oh thank you if
you're following their box houses or
viewing them
when they're not used to it
okay there we go where's everybody
coming from trucks the maybes thank you
so much for the follow
up alana raid what wait hold on
excuse me because you guys have to go
through searching the [ __ ] titles to
find these people is there a raid coming
through one no
no stop you judged oh my gosh what the
heck
hold on aphrodiliac thank you for the
follow super saiyan xp thank you for the
follow big dave thank you for the follow
lunar dictator thank you for the follow
probably we're getting charity streams
there we go there it is [ __ ] what
[Laughter]
alana pierce what the [ __ ] that's what
we're here for
why didn't a notification go off for
that oh my god
a lot of peers
that's why because you all were
following so the notification didn't
cost
you ruined thank you so so much for that
generous donation
i am losing my mind everybody that's
coming through there's too many
wonderful people in here to thank but
thank you guys so much
hi we just crushed oh my god
elana pierce wherever you are
find me please i need to send you a gift
basket from hawaii
oh that would be so cute it was a secret
rate i didn't get the rain notification
so i wanted to read my mind
oh my god oh my god
i'm oh my god okay hi hi everybody
wow wow she's just a fan
she's oh my god
well thank you you guys my night is
completely made
holy [ __ ] my night was already amazing
and somehow it just got a little bit
more [ __ ] amazing
hold on okay i need to pull up really
quick because i'm losing track
oh my god there's so many [ __ ] people
that i i can't see stream but there are
so many wonderful people that have
followed
and i am losing my mind right now so
we're going to go through this she's
like off
literally there's been so many followers
in the past
i'm 100 convinced 2000 yeah
okay i don't pay attention to viewer
accounts
but i don't need to to know that you
guys are wonderful and
it's i'm great oh my god
oh nico also donated 35 thank you so
much i
am hold on hold on
i i physically have to open up
streamlabs so i can individually thank
you guys for following thank you guys so
much i'm losing
i'm losing uh control right now a lot of
peers coming through donating to the
2000 thank you so so much
the money that you are donating is going
towards the lgbtq freedom fund which is
a bail fund to help
lgbtq folks get them out of the system
and get them back to living normal lives
it's a wonderful cause that i personally
believe in
because i do not love the system that
places people at a disadvantage
and also i do not love the fact that
it is not a level playing field so by
donating you are supporting a wonderful
cause
we crushed it though wow i see that one
how is it good to see you
[Music]
all right so right now i am sewing a hat
i'm making the hat for
the uh for a misfortune uh
cosplay candy cane fortune which is in
the top corner over there
i am personally uh just starting off
with cosplay so this is all uh something
that
i am keeping in the picture beginning
with i would never have enough stuff to
do that
oh my gosh so what if i fantastic
charity what a fantastic person thank
you so much for coming in with the party
i really appreciate it
wow everybody that's coming through and
following thank you so so much
i am going to go through and thank
everybody individually
that's a lot of people decide being
spike driver uh the maybe uh aphrodiliac
the big dave oh it's a claws my cause
that makes complete sense
thank you so much for closing my cause i
appreciate it anytime uh
the big dave lunar dictator thank you
for the follow two hands one controlling
thank you for the follow
a captain concert thank you for the
following thank you for the ball
uh uh amber thank you
1747 thank you for the follow velvety
played it better
boy hiatus thank you for the follow
rainbow rose thanks for the follow i
lost track uh don't do that
you have a tito sorry thank you for the
follow drink the jet thank you for the
follow eska botos thank you for the
follow octavian 31 thanks for the follow
era i'm sorry about you i'm thankful for
the follow up
rehash thank you for the follow-up
should be harley quinn thank you
uh fleet admiral retired delirious
i really do want to thank everybody
right now thank you so much till defy of
course you're welcome
all right yes
carlos was gaming who could it be
nobody knows nobody does
all this free advertising damn you
okay oh our first fortnight player
they are raising money for no kid hungry
i did one of those this
this uh this month last one
i'm right over his face though
there we go this should work
[Music]
he's currently raised like 110 of a
thousand i think
what's up my dudes thank you for the
whatever you're doing
oh it says the name of the top of add
damn it there's nothing i can do about
that
it sucks that i have to do this though
you guys are awful this is really shitty
i can't go full screen when i switch
it's not an option i can't do it
oh my god
uh what happened there this is the worst
i really couldn't hear anything once
this thing started going off
[Music]
yo what up thank you for the uh
everything wait i missed when i was
donation went through it went through
leader green
instead of angry girl it's positive joe
love it thanks man all right
they blew it again every time every time
gotcha gotcha
i don't even think i saw the raid huh
because it's not a raid
is that cheating wait a minute
[Music]
wait a minute yo
a thousand dollars
no waited
hold on a second holy crap
whoa wait
what is going on holy cow hold on let me
switch this over
holy crap
that is ten thousand meals you guys are
insane
you guys are absolutely insane they all
have the coolest emotes look at this
dude i gotta check i gotta check this
person
thank you so much that's amazing i'm
glad you were able to see me just get
absolutely destroyed
i feel like i did all right didn't he
get 10th holy cow
not that bad you do just fine there are
so many followers
i'm not going to turn off the i'm not
going to turn off the alerts we're going
to go through all this
oh holy crap all of the um
guys all of the uh donations that you're
giving and everything
are um going directly no kid hungry this
month oh that's the best even his
donations are going through all the subs
all the all that's amazing
all that stuff holy cow and uh
my dog is gonna be super happy because
there is a uh okay okay
i figured out what i'm gonna have to do
which is hide it from from chat
completely
initially which sucks so bad but uh this
is positive joe for the record
200 uh my crypto thing goes off there
and it gives
my dog
that dog's gonna get a lot of treats oh
my gosh nah man no i'm not very good
that's so funny
thank you though i appreciate it yeah
that's right my dog i love my dog
no i don't think it is oh
yo drake with the five dollars don't get
hungry let's go
the [ __ ] dog like look what's
happening to the dog
that's so funny let me out oh my gosh
let me pull up saltify here real quick
yo i think thank you for the
subscription man like i said all subs
and everything bits
all that stuff goes to nokia hungry
night you guys are nuts yeah bean bag
he's doing everything for that that's so
cool
oh that's so cool it's like the entire
container of being hell yeah
so that's gonna be fantastic i'm really
excited about it that dog's just living
its
best life oh my gosh insane i'm saying
thank you so much for the raid i
appreciate you so much
um really really appreciate it we did it
before we meant to but you're still
welcome paul
okay cow so here's what i'm gonna have
to do
yeah that's raymond she's a um she's a
lab pit mix
she has like the she's beautiful yo jtb
with ten dollars okay
not able to keep up definitely the dog
is having a great time
so good yeah she doesn't know what to do
with herself
i love it yeah i said lab pit mix yeah
yeah beautiful though
what's awesome about her is that she has
like the the temperament of a lab
and the love of the pit so it's like
literally perfect she's got a little
white spot under a chip
she's literally perfect oh very cute
okay
here's what we're gonna do is pull this
all the way over here
do you guys just have to deal with me in
this direction let's see here
and then we got this
all right i think this is gonna work
hopefully
[Music]
this
what is this oh he's playing twitch
sings
[Music]
this is for mental health new zealand i
think
it probably even gave you is too much
information
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
500 no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no we can
make that happen
we can make that happen
[Music]
he's having a great time
you guys have just done it again already
so i have to mute it now too hi all
right
[Music]
he stopped because it was too high i
can't hit that
i love a kiwi i love a kiwi that's so
funny
oh you people suck they're already in
the chat so what's the point
what's the point here we go already
ruined it
uh so i guess i have to not tell you the
game or what they're raising money for
or anything else
there we go
[Music]
a tremendous amount of lyrical variety
[Music]
oh my god what's happening
rainbow underscore rose has joined the
orchard oh my god it's so loud
hi i'm so sorry that you came in on
there oh my god
how hello has joined the orchard that's
so funny
how far oh my god who's calling hello
dirk malloy 85
has joined the orchard hello hello hi
new zealand accents so funny hello drake
the gin has joined the orchard
i don't get the right notification who's
writing
oh my god are you calling hello have
already challenged train has joined the
orchard
what's happening
oh my god who's calling hello silver fur
werewolf has joined the orchard
i'm trying to figure out a way on the
back end to stop you guys from mike from
doing this
hello what he still hasn't noticed the
donation
[Laughter]
wait what's happening but he's having a
good time
he's calling hello kung fu matador has
joined the orchard what
that was such a funny song for us to
join us
that's her name hi oh
what is happening what what is happening
hello
demon underscore steven has joined the
orchard
what oh my god he's calling hello
retired what's happening
hello everyone hi who's calling hello
doctor
this is the absolute cutest oh my god
who's calling hello
ask about us has joined the orchard no
no what
oh my god are you hello if silos has
joined the orchard
are you i think he's just seen the
donations i think that's what's just
happened
madden beast 232 has joined the orchard
oh my god who's calling hello ferret 42
has joined the yorkshire
has joined the orchard thank you so much
for that donation uh
oh my god undead underscore witcher has
joined the orchard
there's so much happening i'm i i'm a
new zealand accent
god has joined the orchard thank you so
much um
oh my god i don't know what's happening
because this is a charity bar
so much hi i'm mr peel i'm a new zealand
ferrari streamer
um spectre underscore number 15 has
joined the orchard
that's a charity right oh my god oh my
god um hello
i'm super saiyan xp has joined yours
sorry so the charity is um
the charity is the mental health
foundation of new zealand brandon c
underscore has joined the orchard
they they they they help with um
creating oh my god
like a society for everybody and
research and and um resources
suffering from mental health seniors the
goal is to try help make new zealand
a mental health like oh my god who's
calling hello
dental to help help increase visibility
of mental health in new zealand and help
also
support you guys struggling hello has
joined the orchard
two hands one controller has joined the
orchard thank you so much oh my god
oh my god hello roth tank has joined the
orchard
what is happening
amazing doom has joined the orchard what
oh my gosh
can someone can oh my god i need i need
a tiny black order team has joined the
yorkshire what's what's her username
what's your username don't worry about
it
i need to no you don't have to worry
about it it's okay it's all you i saw
you
gaming has joined the orchard oh my god
i'm sorry ray ray i'm so sorry you got
time down
hold up let me light this up hello
he's someone that he's playing a game
with that's so funny
hell yeah roll up cheat x 100
thank you thank you sorry if everyone
gets timed out the bot times people out
for posting links i should have i should
have thought about that before i asked
for it i'm so sorry hello
ex-tech has joined the orchard oh my god
oh my god he's calling hello captain
construct has joined the orchard oh my
god
i love it everyone has their own
reaction in this dude
who's calling hello dj thug murder has
joined the orchard
it's the absolute cutest oh my god who's
calling hello jesus
1719 has joined the orchard okay
oh my god who's calling hello pacific
voltage club has joined the orchard
my cheeks genuinely hurt smiling
has joined the orchard thank you thank
you so much
delightful human oh my god who's calling
hello
has joined the orchard yo y'all have
broken me
i mean oh my god hello hazard
has joined me okay okay okay we gotta
move back oh everything just
i'm i'm going through too much stuff
every single person that followed that
gave bits that subscribe everything like
that
oh my god thank you so much everybody at
99 has joined the audience
thank you for that donation as well
everything just just disappeared
oh yeah x100
the the bot is so far behind this backup
and i was at last okay
oh my god muting that
jumping on a new one
okay here we go
see you can't hear it or see it
okay and then i will unmute
and turn it back on yep uh tiltify i'm
ready let's go let's go let's go let's
go
tell me when you pushed it i guess so i
know what to do
thanks for the shout out kippy there we
go we've got it
before the chat got there he hasn't
noticed it yet though
oh my
[Music]
wow alana pierce
thank you for the one thousand dollar
donation
holy macaroni oh
and he had a 500 goal i'm doing well how
are you
oh my goodness thank you so much
my goodness man there we go
give me a heart attack no i don't want
that thank you for the raid too i don't
want any of that
wow thank you oh my goodness
those of you well money ray holy criminy
he said holy crap man we just got raided
oh i'm well thank you
um those who don't know who i am i'm
super paladin tv
uh our paladin from super paladin tv i'm
playing phasma phobia
i'm a variety streamer mostly but i'm
here just to
raise money for make a wish foundation
so thank you
i got a donation get you up on the bed
they get anonymous for the five dollar
donation appreciate it
oh i have but i thought i saw it spawn
on the bed one time so i'm not sure
that is a thick accent you could
probably go up the steps just like we
did
yeah i don't think it's a um reverend no
he's just back to play the game i
respect it
what was the third piece of evidence
that we had he's just back on it what
kind of ghost is it though
could be revenant could be
uh he went from eight viewers to 300
viewers for the record unfortunately you
know the king of spades thank you to 10
donation oh my goodness you guys are
awesome
there's no really easy way for me to do
this jtb thank you for the 10
donation thank you
but what kind of ghost is it though wow
he and his friends could die you know
dirty water which we probably won't get
since he's not in the bathroom and we
need a food
those accents are so thick thank you
yeah thank you for the donation you guys
are very kind i really appreciate it
i mean he's definitely still shook i
love it i love how many different
reactions there this is so honestly so
good
stay hydrated
hi
thank you anonymous for the 10 donation
and appreciate it
wow 1370
my goodness hell yeah i'm actually
well this channel is not affiliated it's
right i'm from wisconsin but i'm i grew
up in north carolina so i do have a
bit of a southern draw i guess i sort of
know that accent sort of
still not that well though um
all right we got another one oh my
goodness
chancellor 87 thank you for the 20
donation i appreciate it
i didn't see it all right got it got it
all right you got a picture of it
all the donations i've been getting just
gave me good luck
hi because we just hit the jackpot today
they get anonymous for five dollars
so all right cool
i love phasmaphobia i think it's really
good too many photos it's a really good
game
did you see the photo of the floating
hand it's kind of creepy
amazing okay okay get rid of this again
and then get rid of this
and then jump up to another one
okay let's do it
um all right
we making it happen
all right tiltify
you ready let's do it
go now
i don't have audio from this stream
though
why has that happened where's the audio
i they have to refresh it
oh i just had it muted of course it is
there you go
that's my bad wait this is the second
round
watch me like not make it because of the
abc
wait it's definitely getting harder to
get to
so many people say wait when they notice
it happens
do you guys see like this donation total
[Music]
there's a stream several months ago
where
somebody was trying to raise money and
twitch donated holy [ __ ]
oh my god my heart is racing
oh my god we like totally went over
our goal someone just donated two
thousand dollars
what oh my gosh oh my god i'm literally
like oh
hell yeah that is so amazing
oh my god for the children
she just completely threw the game away
i love it the dedication that's so cute
so at that price is it like a cream pie
full of spiders and scorpions
oh my god it's gotta be yeah she has
it has two thousand dollars eat a
scorpion and a tarantula
made it that is so amazing do you have
to do that now and we're getting raided
oh my god this is so amazing
i'm like actually like how much
i know charity bomb
wow alana thank you so much i cannot
believe we just hit over
oh my god yeah we're gonna eat a
scorpion i'm gonna eat a scorpion and a
tarantula
and i'm gonna get pie a pie to the face
oh my god so what what you guys
just alana what you just what you just
donated to
was for the association to benefit
children
it is an amazing organization um that
helps kids from like ages five
all the way up to 21 and they help so
many they
they help change so many lives so thank
you thank you so much for that i am like
just
in in shock
you don't have to eat them i i do i
definitely have to eat them
oh she for sure um let me let me show
you guys
oh my god that is i'm like hooked
oh what's going to happen
i am so like i'm shaking right now like
i cannot
eat any spiders yeah yo
thank you so much
no i have it i have it right here i'm so
last night
we uh last night we started the charity
and uh the the things that i had to do
are right here on the bottom so at 100
i had to eat a buffet of baby food at a
250 i ate a couple raw eggs um
i blew up a giant triceratops costume
and i played a couple games but it was
really really tough
come on in and out in a giant bathroom
costume
at 7 50 um i blended up
some onions and garlic and cucumber and
strawberry banana and i
drank that um at a thousand i did a
workout stream
at 1200 i ate cat food yeah i'm waiting
partying
captain not recommend eating cat food
just if anyone was interested i had
turkey gravy
it does not taste like turkey or gravy
so definitely would not
eat cat food but we did it for the
children
this is it is very cool
at 2 000 at 2 000 i
am hooked up this happening
oh my god yeah i got let me just get
shaking i cannot believe how much we hit
i was like that alert didn't even come
up yet and the bar went up to like past
three thousand and i just i was like is
my stuff broken
like what just happens and i'm just
this is so amazing oh my god
come on pull through not now i'm here to
see a woman in scorpio debut
i love that she got eliminated
immediately it's so funny
yeah my internet got kept because i had
to download cyberpunk like four times
it's a bummer no we just got 20 gifted
subs
oh my god i can't come alone come on
buddy i just want to see the woman eat
scorpion
oh my god thank you anonymous for the 20
gifted subs
oh my god guys
and all the bits and all the subs are
also going towards
the charities that whatever we earned
during
during the charity um was all going
towards them so thank you so much oh my
god i cannot believe
that we hit this is this the last night
of charity goal
oh my god yeah this is the last night
and then i'm going yeah i
nailed it and
i cannot believe how much we raised for
them this is like
absolutely insane
oh my gosh
oh i'm yeah we're gonna we're gonna eat
this right now i'm actually
okay i'm going to like quit out not yet
thank you so much for the 10 10 gifted
subs
oh my god i cannot believe that this is
happening
oh people just say buddies is slang
there you go okay again i'm very
and what i have done to you i'm so sorry
i just need to grab like
hey just eat them one speed how are all
these women
a bunch of goddesses really okay so eat
it okay yeah she left the potty she
bounced get out of there
you don't need them no i i mean i got it
off amazon so
it should be safe i checked the reviews
and i've watched people eat it
so i don't i don't think um
i don't think i'll be like sick
i just think i'll be sick for me you
know what i mean it's like two different
six all right hold on okay give me
give me one second let me just grab
something to drink
that's that you gotta wash the tarantula
down you gotta wash down the tarantula
that you bought on amazon you know
so i get it
[Laughter]
okay uh
okay we have another one but i am gonna
i'm gonna wait for this woman to
that's exciting okay okay we gotta wait
i'm
i'm committed i hope she's okay i really
hope she's okay
okay so we're gonna go into big face
yeah
let me let me go into giant face oh my
god i cannot believe
alana i cannot believe like this is so
amazing thank you so much
for the children we're gonna okay
we are going to i'm so ready
you gotta turn the thing up so we can
see you eat oh my god what should we eat
first
should we eat the spider first okay or
should we eat the
no not now come on
grab taco every time it's only in 360. i
feel like there's gonna be something
that's missing
go big with delicious nachos all your
favorites nacho's party pack only at
taco bell
get yours with taco bell i better not be
missing it
oh it's her internet oh good to know
okay
i'm actually shaking
kill the widgets okay let me so
okay okay this is wild remove it right
this is absolutely wild
okay is that better that's good
ah this might like okay
what are we what are we doing first
spider or the scorpion
it smells really gross i got the
scorpion i think
scorpion should we do a spider scorpion
i don't want to see someone eat a
scorpion
yeah you see so in the background
i'm obsessed with a batman oh yeah and
stuff so
i have like a whole i have a whole
batman
sleeve scorpion first
feel like joker on that that's neat
i'm scared okay wait so the claw
i just broke the cloth i feel like it's
gonna come alive it's so weird
okay this is the tail oh my god
i'm shaking right now i'm so sorry
oh it seems like it's huge so this is
the claw
do i want to see this am i going to be
upset
and is it the claw oh my god i almost
dropped it
i'm going to eat the claw first since
it's
maybe i should eat this
how is that so crunchy excuse me you
take a tortilla chip
it's just like sticking out of my breath
it's not bad
it's so crunchy she looks like she's in
pain oh no i'm so sorry
tell me you're okay please be okay sarah
anyone
if anyone has tasted dried shrimp
oh that's okay that's not that bad
like the tiny dried shrimp that you
would get yeah that's okay
she's still she seems fine let's eat the
i cannot believe how crunchy that is
oh my gosh
[Laughter]
all right i'm okay i'm okay
so far it tastes i just have to tell
myself she's way brighter than me i
would have way more trouble with this
it just tastes like a bunch of dried
shrimp
it's very fine what a champion can you
guys hear it it's so crunchy
would i eat this regularly no
[Laughter]
there's like a weird aftertaste
oh my gosh
wow oh my god look at this claw though
okay look at that okay okay we have
another one okay
this one also has a goal that i think
that should be really funny
all right the sound
is so oh my god
i'm sorry it's so loud visceral
for the children it's okay it's for the
children it's right it's right it's
right
what a champion she she she nailed it
and now you're careful for the tail yeah
we gotta do that we gotta stay for the
tail
absolutely just smash through it you're
a beast
we did it
oh i believe the kids did sit down with
some pagans some soda
that was pogba's it is so crunchy i
believe
this is what they say am i correct did i
say it right oh my god
all right okay great next is the spider
okay i'm freaking out about
i'm freaking out about this i'm sorry
sorry i'm not nope
i can't be a part of this i can't have
anything to do with any of this i'm not
doing it
i'm out you guys can watch that if you
want but i'm not watching it
okay i
am
well they're already swearing two
viewers
we gotta we gotta we gotta make this
happen we gotta make this happen
okay all right go for it hit the
donation
let's go let's go let's go scent
stop talking
i think another
there we go they had two viewers
anyways i had like a hundred dollars
that's my award now
so let's follow how about you guys we're
following
enter the hotel grand lake again this is
amazing
looks like it would really do with some
service
uh it's not really
the upkeep is not very well kept they're
really they're just into it man they're
just into it
you know dust sometimes you gotta get
into it
yeah it is yeah it is not
not as nice i was their only viewer when
that happened i love that that's so good
come on come on you guys notice come on
and mainly a lot of the business from
this hotel this is going to be
incredible they're going to go from one
viewer
just in baleston there's a multitude to
however many
come on no notice come on come on you
guys you guys
in the area he's into his craft though
i gotta respect him for that tourism
he's getting into the crop
it's so weird
yeah well he explains all that
i don't really have much to offer you
except for uh
these three passes i'm gonna listen
i don't want to send you guys the link
people have already found it obviously
but
i'll send it when they notice the
donation never been there yeah i don't
want to send it yet
he hands you one and hands you one this
is incredible
yeah they're lifetime passes so don't
ever have to
you should have said that sooner don't
ever have to pay to go into the great
march
dude his phone
so about that
yeah we're [ __ ] hella rich you don't
got no fighting dragons around here
we interrupt this pre-recorded episode
oh it's pre-recorded
um that makes sense
oh my god holy
mother of oh my god
uh okay okay okay okay here we go
what is happening
what is happening it went from one villa
i love it that's the best part
i don't think twitch has has fully just
like you know
uh populated what how many uh
how many is this raid i don't [ __ ]
know it's not a race
twitch hasn't hasn't told me she's not a
raid um yeah
charity um i'm trying to flow
oh my gosh it's it's it i i ruined it
it's okay oh okay
alana pierce oh not a raid not a raid
okay
he can't see how much she's raced okay
um
this is amazing i ruined the
pre-recorded episode i'll do a i'll do a
rerun of it later
oh my gosh i think he's probably trying
to find out what's happening holy [ __ ]
he is he's definitely trying to figure
out what's happening
she down the whole spider that's
incredible
thank you all so much holy [ __ ]
they went from one to 400. that's insane
i was the one tiny stream and i don't
know what's going
[Laughter]
um are they nearby where are the rest of
the
where was the dude who was discord right
now [ __ ] ripping that vape
where's he at he was going hard
oh my god
the excitement is incredible i want to
know what happened
i want to know what happened to um in in
their their pokemon dnd though
can i join the club is this the thing
you guys could do over the internet so i
could come through
i'm shaking i am shaking
that's my fault i did that that's my
presence oh my god
oh my god holy [ __ ]
oh man oh my god
oh my god they literally went for one
viewer that is the absolute best
with um yes mr randoms and all the
people are streaming for charity
oh my god
[Laughter]
i just did an anti-vaping yet you can't
you can't do me like this
oh my god oh my god
um i could start the episode over from
the beginning because it's pre-recorded
let's get super into it oh my god
what a terrible episode to be
pre-recorded though oh my god
you you've hit all of our all of our
incentives
because we we have a special one shot
that we were
uh doing i have to i have to look at the
at the donation maybe i can find that do
they have where is that 2
155 oh my god
it is here we go oh my god
do they have their incentives on the um
did i tiltify i
i have to how i uh
um let me see where are they let me see
where is
where is it called they did have it
somewhere why can't i do it here oh my
god i'm freaking out
i'm freaking out so hard because one of
them said that they were going to shave
their beards i've
i've made them all shave their beards
it's what's happened to you it's red
nose day and i'm
i've been trying to copy the freaking
they
[Music]
i'm all over the place okay there there
it is there it is there it is it's it is
in the screen streaming's hot ladies and
gentlemen
yeah i have to i have to shave my beard
i have to shave my beard
yeah you do do does everybody want me to
do it now i can literally do it right
yeah
yes i will go get
uh the shaving cream yes and i will
shave it right now
okay literally give me give me just a
couple seconds
oh this is amazing oh my gosh oh my god
i i just hope all these people are okay
with the things that they're doing
hey they signed up for it they signed up
for it i didn't make them do that
you know
oh my gosh oh you can mouse over the
little ah thank you
okay okay let me try that again so what
were the
one shot dnd game okay 24 hour live
stream karaoke live stream
400 anthony shaves his beard 500
ricoh shapes his beard there you go if
you want to if you want to be part of
the pokemon dnd alana
um [ __ ] yeah dm me dmc i
okay i might genuinely do that i just
joined them for one we could do it we'll
have you on as a guest
um and maybe if you want to be part of
the campaign too hell yeah
i think that would be super cool like
i'm genuinely super into it
[Laughter]
here it goes it's all going on
he's not even hesitating these people
are just so brave
this would happen i was not prepared i'm
putting on way too much shaving cream
but whatever
i really hope i don't cut myself on
stream this is going to suck
oh well yeah we don't want this man to
accidentally kill himself
that would be i don't even know okay a
huge problem
oh i have too much hair i should have
that is going to be tough i should have
taken a pic to it for uh
electric razor do it for yeah you're
gonna have a tough time i'm just
that's a lot of here we go it's gonna
take you a while just gotta keep going
no i don't think i think you're just
gonna flatten it mate i think
it's not tracking right i think you're
gonna need different apparatus
it's in the way still okay
it's not gonna work let me get a bowl
with some water
that will help yes or a different razor
i'm i'm freaking out guys
he had one viewer can you imagine if
they never saw the whole thing
if they just missed the entire stream
because it was pre-recorded and they had
no idea
we didn't expect that we didn't expect
that
oh my gosh
okay so we have
two more maybe but i will
wait for this man to to do is shaving
okay we ought to watch this we gotta i
gotta watch this beard come off
you know what i'm saying
and now i just want to join the dmd
campaign
oh i could check back in on him that's
not a bad that's not a bad point
apparently spider girl ate spider the
guy who didn't know
who i was did end up figuring out
what had happened but it took him like
15 minutes which is also awesome
um she's taking the pie now there you go
very good she's ripping her eyelash
herself why she doing that
i guess she could do that she shuts off
all the shaving cream
uh you got to do this differently mate
because i was going to do an electric
razor and i found out my electric razor
is not charged
so we are we're just going to do this
nice and slow though not as much shaving
cream
but i'm going to i'm worried about you
nice and easy
and i started with the wrong side and
i'm going to move
don't shave your please please please
please see myself
on my main monitor but here it comes
this is going to be tough 165 oh
okay so
oh that you know it's just gonna take a
long time
you did have to get the bottle of water
yeah yeah yeah you did need to do that
that was important
yeah this is just gonna get so clogged
also i don't know because i'm a woman
when you shave
are you supposed to shave down do you
shave up
i genuinely have no idea do you shave up
on your face i would think oh you shave
down okay
there you go there you go why
is it so it doesn't give you a rash
down and then up is it so that like you
you like thin it out first maybe okay
bowl with water just don't want to get
it on any of my
see that you're saying down but i'm
still not sure why down
if i can clean off the razor
okay so
this is gonna get better it's gonna get
better okay okay okay
okay just calm down rico
just calm down yeah that worked my
grandfather was good with a straight
razor but he never taught me
so
it's coming off this is gonna come off
it's gonna work i believe in him it's
gonna work
i'm going to call uh
my uh my partner in this endeavor
anthony because anthony has to shave too
i'm pretty sure
ride or die and he's going to flip he
has to shave as well he has to shave as
well
you're both out here shaving anthony are
you there
anthony anthony please still calling him
come on anthony pick up pick up damn you
oh yeah he has to shave his head he has
to shave his whole head
oh my gosh anthony anthony i need you to
get on twitch
right the [ __ ] now
go on our stream and see what happened i
had to interrupt
the pre-recorded pokemon episode
i can't hear him very well
okay yeah you gotta you gotta get here
you're getting there but you're getting
there um
i can't be calm right now anthony you'll
understand
yes whole head chat
oh don't worry i'm not going to cut
myself i hope not that was a good one
that was oh you're moving around so much
come on bud
yeah you're getting it you get you do it
you do it
now
[Music]
i'm trying to get anthony's reaction
no he's not he you didn't wake him up
we're fine he's
he's still up he's a night owl
am a why why is the number 341
the no the number is 341
alana pierce donated two thousand
dollars
what happened
it just happened oh my god sitting here
talking to brittany just on the phone
and then all of a sudden i see i see the
number go
from 105 to 2105
and i go i think i'm going to cry right
now that's
amazing oh cesar ladies what do i need a
charity
um all of it is going to charge so this
is going to red nose day
which is helping kids who need it they
are
the most amazing people ever because
they're here
hanging out as i'm sure all these people
are so
funny rico
the number the number just went up in
viewers it was
it was a different number uh i was
looking at a completely different number
rico who told
people about us i don't know i don't
know stream
i don't know let me give you guys a link
because i love that he's panicking
about the number changing that's my
favorite bit there you go
oh sorry yeah okay we'll keep it we'll
keep it pg we'll keep it pg
fine i don't mind it's okay
yeah it just it this doesn't shout out
to anthony though
at all oh no
it just kind of happened all of a sudden
it's it's so
anthony alana pierce says hello
hello
oh my gosh
oh christian christian another uh speak
at you is another
member of our team and he just jumped in
and
oh my god thank you for the subscription
what are the seven did you guys just do
the 700. there's so many things
happening
you guys just do that and someone else
do that shaving you guys
i feel like you guys just did that
correct rico we put the number of 500
for this um charity yes that was our
goal
because we wanted to contribute we
wanted to do something and we don't
really have an audience and all of a
sudden
um this happened and it is more than
twice
it's more than four times it's 800
people though they have
one when we started nations are coming
in
uh 555 anonymous 100 barry block
oh my gosh
you're shaving your face i just noticed
what you're doing
get on zoom and i will get you on there
and we'll do this right now
it doesn't
the people have called for your head to
be shaved
it's true they haven't they called for
my beard to go away
and i am giving the people a good job so
we are giving
the people what they want
[ __ ] you rico you guys we're so close to
a thousand this is nuts again i was the
only viewer
oh my god this is the most amazing thing
ever never seen a man so happy to shave
his own face
all right all right um alana pierce
wants to see you shave
it's really oh no i can't i'm not
leaving the stash everything's gone
okay okay i think i'm gonna leave this
one open i'm gonna
this is the first time and then should
we jump to the
maybe i don't next maybe you should just
rock rocks
oh my gosh i would but i'm good with
just a stash
but i've also i'm i'll i'll leave the
stash before i shave it off i won't
shave the stash off i'll finish the
beard this is incredible
this is our last chance
shall be memorized
i love them yeah we'll wait for the
thousand wait for the thousand and then
i think there was i think there was four
because ymca
[Music]
and i'll get you i'll get you on a zoom
call i have to reapply more shaving
cream
oh my god this is so
good oh my god shaving cream
gonna make sure i'm doing it on the
right side because everything's inverted
you're doing a great job you've improved
so much we're so proud of you
you're doing an incredible job
and i'll just use a little bit more on
this side just so i can
have it ready we're at
and two 2502 now but now anthony saw the
phone
times the goal that we had set
um i i don't have words and i'm going to
wash this jacket later you guys are
donating as well that's awesome
to wipe off the shaving cream so i can
use this you can watch that you can
watch that well
actually don't worry about my right hand
but now i'm
well i've been using my right hand i
guess i don't even know
there are things happening just don't
hurt yourself please oh my god please oh
my gosh
oh my god please i think anthony'd be
really excited about the thousand but
he's got to get his gear ready to shave
his head
so let's get some let's get some music
going because
the silence is uh the silence is nice
but
okay i'm scared that i'm gonna get
demonetized some music going so i'm
going to beat you sir
wait i can't i can't i can't
that's not gonna work okay i think i
need to leave the stream let's do some
okay some royalty-free jrpg music
happy to hear that then that's great i
love that from you
um but i'm gonna mute this one and we
will jump over
to send someone else some donations here
okay
i need to do this real quick
and then this
okay okay okay okay
this is a test stream this is gonna be
great
okay
okay
like lego mario rpg style thing and just
like did it as a story
and like donated you know obviously sex
don't have to be
what the heck
you can't do that did you see that wait
i could do that i could totally do that
[Music]
yeah
this yeah what the heck
do i have to do i have to like call all
my friends what the heck
what are you doing this is amazing
planning but plans change
because my cause delivered clause my
cons
delivered prolep thank you for the
follow
and what is hap guys am i being raided
what the [ __ ] guys guys
you guys can't do this to me don't do
this to me right now
guys stop this hi i'm saying stop this
because we're not doing the charity
stream right now
when we race all the money sends her
[Music]
alana pierce i'm
flipping out tiltify is now following i
freaking amusing tiltify
but the stream is on friday
i do i don't even know what are you guys
doing hey
this is i guess do i have to start the
charity why
oh my freaking goodness this is the
biggest rate i've ever gotten in my
entire freaking life
a billion of you guys came out of
nowhere a billion of you guys are
following thank you all so much
uh hit the discord guys i mean it
doesn't clock man
because this is this thing right now so
like it all right all right
um hi um i love you guys
what do you guys want me to play name
any game under the sun
i probably i might have it and we can we
can figure things out from there
um because now i got to make this a big
stream because
now i'm under pressure guys um
let me at my friends real quick you say
you gotta ask your friends
gotta at your friends here and you gotta
call your anthony's
i love that everyone's like i tell my
friends tell my friends
real quick look how happy he is please
okay i do want to see how spunky dragons
is doing still just still just out here
shaving that bead
shaving that be it good stuff good stuff
yeah lather it up yeah anyway
hi uh you guys are just hanging out
having a good time yeah all right i'll
tell you about our charity you know
that's a wonderful place to start
um because thank you so much
that's a wonderful place um i was just
like i was just chilling here like going
through
my lego mario fan fiction and
220 people pop out of nowhere and
i get a thousand dollars in donations
for a charity stream that i've been
planning
for months and we're not even doing yet
what the heck are you guys doing
um okay okay alana's still arrived
did she find me did she like is she just
popping in and saying hello um
but anyway yeah let me tell you about my
charity um why not
so uh essentially what we have going on
here is we are doing an
annual fundraising fundraiser for the
american foundation for suicide
prevention
exactly larcenator that's what's going
on here i was talking about my lego
mario fanfic ideas
and how i wanted to make like a little
youtube series and
all of a sudden i'm put on blast like
you guys were you guys were waiting for
this
um a little bit yeah it's funny because
like this is the exact same
i was watching a mr beast video earlier
and i was like man
how would i react if somebody just like
popped in and donated a bunch of money
to you told us to stop but
streaming for no viewers and you
freaking
freaks came out here and did i should
probably go grab water to hydrate how
does one get a link to it
well i haven't made it yet i want to
make it but i haven't decided let me go
grab a water
okay okay we'll check back in this i
think my youtube link is there
doing great i don't know what he's
talking about but he's still out here
shaving
guys i have so many like plot threads
going through my head right now i feel
like i need to talk about something
for a little bit and thank you i'm
worried about your readers and thank you
all for the bits and everything
i don't know what i'm talking about
actually half of all of the
subs are going to be going to the stream
all my donation links should take you
exactly to the charity
um so i'll talk about i'll talk about
the bionicles i'll talk about the paper
mario fanfics
um i'll talk about the charity first
let's start there um so we
this is the fifth year that we've done
this um this is the a fundraiser for the
american foundation for suicide
prevention
also thank you all for the hype train um
i host this alongside my friends um we
kind of we host it here so as you can
see
we've been trying to get the cameras and
stuff set up that's what i've been doing
here tonight getting the um
the five is for the fifth year right
right right uh
it's a fifty dollars like a face cam i
should probably make a face cam
all right charity rating in partnership
with tiltify basically hop in on random
streams using tiltify and
blast out the progress bar gotcha okay
that makes sense thank you thank you to
whoever explained that
yeah can i shave my beard no you don't
do that no don't make him do that
donation goal no he doesn't have to do
that maybe i'll do it all right i'm
crushing i have friends with
much larger beards than mine maybe how
is rico doing um
literally this is a non-stop stream
follows and hosts and everything
thank you all um what was i saying all
right i'll keep my beard i'll keep my
beard
shave i'll shave my head don't have to
do any shavings
listen to chat i don't know what's going
on
man um still kicking in you guys are
literally consistent with the fallers i
don't know what you guys are doing going
on here
um but this is the fifth year we've done
this
we've raised over ten thousand dollars
lifetime
and since it was our fifth year we
thought it was our best idea
to do you know five thousand five years
kind of put all the fives out there last
year we got four thousand six hundred
that's so cool
but obviously we haven't even started
and we're at a thousand six hundred
fifty two
oh i oh oh oh you guys i get to do this
hold up what are you doing let's see
where is it
all right normally what we do when we
have
oh let me i haven't i don't even have my
tiltify donations up let me get those up
um normally when we
set up something like this and when we
have
people who donate yeah such as all of
you all um you guys
have been donating oh my goodness that's
so much money um i don't even know if i
can handle this all right now i'll at
least get alana
and then trust me on friday we'll get
all the rest done when i have my crew
um when we get a donation of sorts oh i
see
christmas tree that you see here on our
left i have to talk a little bit louder
since i'm further away from my
microphone
because our audio guy is coming tomorrow
to help us set this all up this is
really cool
this is so neat that they do this it's
like a little bit in shambles right now
um normally we take one of these
beautiful little
labels right we put it on a beautiful
bulb such as this
um this one's cool they're decorating a
tree
who have been such a wonderful donor um
so far since we've actually just started
very cool just like this this is the
best
i just want to implore anyone who's
watching to do this to like get together
with your friends and raise money for
charity is the best that's so cool
right thankfully they just have a good
time they set up their cameras with
their audio
you probably won't be able to read it
from there once every year
you guys uh for doing something
wonderful you're going to start out with
the big gold bulb
um as our sort of top donor
slide it on right there
amazing
so thank you all thank you for the
donations um totally over 1
600 have i missed anything else so far
hey we got to help this dude raise money
[Music]
so let me go ahead and say trying to
erase that five points
putting this at a thousand six hundred
fifty seven we get the arigato's
shaving guys stop here he's getting
literally non-stop
um are you on the phone back to the main
game scene for now
um what are you looking for show them
i've done nothing guys i've done nothing
for you all
except freaked out because i'm genuinely
oh so oh so also very excited guys um
thank you so much
really really really lovely i was a
little worried this year because of
covid and everything
we maybe weren't going to be able to
reach our goal we haven't even started
this is such a great start exactly bird
watcher
you guys are sweet are you kidding me i
think this is the example
follows i literally can't stop because
the
the the stream of follows that is going
on everybody about to shave his head
these my friends okay legitimately won't
believe it we gotta jump back to this
dude friday anyone who's free friday's
parties are doing a challenge
you guys would like to raid
um bird boy do you mind uh sharing that
command one more time
and getting amazing here okay okay
anyone who wants to tell everybody
something something crazy is going on
right now and i've got no clue what's
happening
yeah you know it is it is what it is
right
jump back over to yes you
oh hello oh how's it grown i can't see
i haven't seen you i mean in a while
let's see well
you're gonna shave here too he's gonna
do it on the carpet
right on the coffee he doesn't care he's
gone for it i have a camera on
i know i hate the other one let me
oh [ __ ] i'm very invested
in uh this is smoking drag i'm trying to
figure out
here off the other camp
i think rico is just having trouble
getting his camera to walk because he's
controlling the stream but we have that
problem
okay i did it okay okay perfect
cop stash rico is he keeping his
mustache
put this on top off
because this is gonna go now okay
this is incredible here we are i'm so
excited i'm so excited
okay and amber uh everybody this is
amber
hello is one of us uh one of a smoking
dragons
and here we go i'm gonna reapply some
more shaving cream he's doing a great
job
i don't need to shave today i'm good
i mean is does she have to shave
weird like one of the side things i have
saved oh wait i can actually change
the inversion on this
oh christian's coming in christian the
whole gang's here
everybody's here
hell no i'm not shaving my head i'm
changing my video settings so i can
mirror my video there we go this will be
easier now you're green
yeah rico's green coming soon i'm doing
it he's doing it he's not looking
actually i can wear some like vomiting
this is terrifying
okay there we go now we got this now
we've got
i guess this is really scary like a
normal person
christian where's your camera my camera
did sushi left right us back that's
really cool
let's turn on that camera christian the
lovely folks wanted to shave your face
did she finish making the desk
goodness anthony is going for it she got
a desk finished
she did like a baby like he'll look like
he went back to like middle school come
on
it's all over his carpet no i'll trim it
but i'll trim it on my own time
how dare you christian you got shaped
for charity i love that royalty free uh
maybe i'll play pokemon for charity
jlpg music good stuff you're doing a
good job come on for someone who is
using a webcam to see
that's true dude watch be careful that's
it
just just shaving it like a boss anthony
you know thank you for joining us sushi
your dog is very cute your cat was also
very cute
i hope you built the desk okay riko's
been shaving his face for like an hour
because i don't have my i would have
gotten my electric razor
to do it but i can't find the charger
hey there i am
there's christian hey christian hey
what's up yeah christian you should just
[ __ ] shave who cares it'll grow back
this happened to your right second one i
had one
i love it so much oh my gosh i shave
your head i
don't need it with my face i'll [ __ ]
come over and shave your head
i will not let you in
your family will let me in he's gonna
have a bad rash rico that's gotta
totally do you're gonna have she wants
to play the she wants to play the
pokemon uh
pokemon d with us i would love to
genuinely i would love to do that not
green on stream
he's literally green for me every time
he talks and i don't know why the issue
with that i guess is timing
but we'll figure something out we will
make it work somehow
rico you can be snatched
eye shadow no no i'm not i just keep
worrying about
all of you and what are you doing to
your faces
rico yeah that seems dangerous but
it wasn't to make anybody else shave or
do anything it was
you got to moisturize that now you gotta
get in trouble honestly
we made that goal so high we didn't
i mean high for us for our reach um
oh yeah were they all sleeping did we
because we thought we didn't we didn't
think we'd get it
we were not trying to ruin your nights
but this this uh no the
the pokemon uh stream was going on
getting
getting this going on now is impromptu i
literally i literally interrupted the
episode
i was just like because i saw it i was
sitting here
i was just sitting here monitoring the
chat and the stream and all that stuff
and then all of a sudden i saw the
number tick from 105 to 2105 and i was
just like
i'm gonna cry what just happened hey
what
what's everyone's what's everyone's
favorite pokemon moniker wants to know
gyarados my favorite pokemon is
dragonite my favorite of all time
i know it's an odd choice that my
favorite pokemon is gyarados but it is
it's gyarados don't ask why just there's
no [ __ ] reason i just i just really
like muna even though they're really bad
i can tell you anthony's favorite
pokemon because he doesn't have his
headphones on right now because he's
shaving his head
um his favorite pokemon is infernape
i'm pretty sure favorite is empoleon
i really respect that they know this
about each other you're good friends i
don't know
my friend's favorite pokemon
i should know them better my favorites
right there it's uh it's an absol
nice nice
then there's there's leafeon above my
head and there's lovely people oh when
you go let's go
i was gonna i was gonna do
this he's just got stripped it actually
looks pretty rad
that like actually looks pretty good
what are you doing
i was i this is what i was going to
aspire to do like you know this top knot
thing going i like it
um i'm being told to keep the hawk
oh well he looks like a pidgeot it's
perfect for them really love goodra
especially if they keep it with the pink
if they put some yellow in it of all
time
but it is so [ __ ] good goodra goodra
is one of my absolute favorite dragon
pokemon and
and i love goodra because it's such a
cutie that hurts you so badly oh
no i i agree alana says anthony's
officiato
is that true look at it you know what
i'm saying
i also like flygon a lot like on his
boss
i like most dragon type pokemon a lot of
people
knowing that just makes me sad he's just
gotta
add like what is it it's pink and yellow
potential
are we okay chat we do i mean do you
want anthony shave his whole head for
for charity
and then pidgeot is like yellow in the
middle
and pink on the outside that's what i
think he should do
is he should do pidgeot this is this is
what can i please campaign
i mean it's it's the pidgeot fair uh
please tell him that i would like
him to have pidgey on hawk okay you
gotta go pick it he's gonna go blond
okay
oh my gosh okay we do have one more
streamer we're currently trying to find
to donate to before i wrap the stream up
this has been a lot of fun though this
is uh
the vibes are good having a pidgey out
mohawk she's
she's requesting the hawk to remain and
make it blonde
agron is boss agron is super [ __ ]
cool
i love okay you guys are just spouting
out i know i know
why don't we why don't we go down like
by typing and name our favorite pokemon
their audio levels are wild but it does
happen it does happen
what type do you want to start with fire
getting him to have a pidgeot hook would
not be that hard he's just got to bleach
the middle part well
bleach the whole thing and then just
separate the sides and make them pink
anthony
that would not be that hard to do but
i'm not going to make this person do
something that it wants to the hair okay
just but i would really like it
i like i like um i like nine tails a lot
rico is doing well the quick the
quickest list for me because i like
he's against the great most of the
pokemon the quickest list for me is the
pokemon i don't like
mr mine oh rico i have a present for you
a solid tape totally making that an
email by the way
a solid take yeah a mystery i never
liked them
there's no way we're not gonna have that
you think rico would like he's so good
then since he looks like that
he's doing a really good job considering
i mean the back of his head's a mess
all right really quick i'm gonna go but
he can't see like power wash this razor
so i can get the last few strokes buddy
oh buddy
oh watch yourself but you be careful
there at three
oh gosh oh gosh i cut my own hair and i
panic and i'm not shaping it
holy [ __ ] there's so many okay okay how
about like
it seems just like hella constantly
though oh he he also doesn't have a set
sit in
i hope i didn't drink that night i don't
know where they are like do these people
have work tomorrow i do
because like what time is it i like it i
don't know so like empoleon if i buy it
by typing
he totally looks like a all right
well there's also someone watching i
absolutely love it
i know i i'm sure i probably didn't
remember using clippers to shave it's
safe is it
you never use them i don't know
you genuinely don't all know
fire type let's go back and look at five
there you go there you go
anthony's looking like a boss over there
he's doing it he's really doing it you
didn't pick yet so i guess
who me no i i still don't really
understand how they work
again i've never had to do it yeah i'm
still looking for fire
safer than a razor i mean that makes
sense
don't okay chat don't keep pressuring
him okay about oh yeah
doing the pidgeot if he doesn't want it
not going to make him do that
we passed the goal they had to shave all
right
they've done it everyone stay hydrated
likes to step on you
i need to get this playlist sorry
of whatever it is that they're listening
to oh just that's my thing
i need to get on jlpg jams for sure
yeah i've always good stuff
[Music]
okay
[Music]
okay i'm picking the last one
rico had judges anthony's just still
going i know
thank you for that i think we've got one
so dm alana your jrpg playlist
i have uh do you have anything i like
the playlist i'm into it
on twitter
uh i think that tiltify for the person
we said that we'll be making a
highlights
but i could make one too sound off
because this is good
so much fun i mean i knew it would be
awesome but definitely
that is extra awesome okay question for
you
okay we're on the last one so like zeno
saga or
dot hygiene i will probably raid these
guys
um towards the end
so that you guys can can jump back in
there when we're done here
but we found our last
stream here we go here we go here we go
um wait for this to end and then we will
jump over
what we want to do is
we've muted that i want to
mute that unmute that
okay
there's a person four viewers
i think you might be australian too
no he's not take it back
done
boom
yeah i think yeah we do yeah we got the
damage yeah boys hell yeah
raising money for make-a-wish
league this is justice this isn't you
got to be in the zone playing league i
get it i get it i get it with the arrow
goal was 500
and we have just donated i love this
hype dude 2 000 i'm going to move over
he can't catch me
[Music]
i just flashed
did hey thanks for the follow gto
they through gto thanks for the follow
bro
if you uh
what the foreign there we go who are
these people on your thing
dude 2 597
for make a wish dude who brought that
well i could i'm all i'm matching up to
250. my wife would slaughter me if i
empty the savings account
some all-star that's some jungle diff
merry christmas yes
that's what it's about here at 33 gaming
oh my goodness did you get hosted
alenia pierce olynyk it's me bringing
the heat with 2500
awesome thank you dude that goal was
500.
destroyed it
wow that is amazing here we go
if you need it up the sale it's got to
be real
for the
[Music]
hey whoever you guys are awesome man
holy cow
dude yeah i don't think zeke can check
it because
it's i mean it's the tilt-a-thigh
here we go that is awesome i'm glad we
could win and do that that's like
yeah dude that means you have to play
the kids
[Music]
[Laughter]
dude it's amazing i love it when it's
multi-player and you hear that friends
react
i think that's the coolest dollar match
that too up to 250 that's what we do
every
every month as we raise money for
charities every month that's [ __ ]
crazy these people are all superstars oh
my god
he's gonna make this man cry
[Music]
dude yeah that that would make me tear
out
z you got the hype train going i can't
give subs man
it's saying something right how did they
get in your stream
[Laughter]
i love it
i have my paypal though yeah you should
do that please do that don't talk to
yourself please don't do that that would
be really bad
don't be a bad lost treated so much
if you like uh what we do here is
raising money for charities
every month you can go back uh me and
drizzy
partner crime we do this every month
that's awesome
your people are amazing this is bigger
than a problem this is bigger than uh
these wins here 12 in a row z did you
think alana
yeah lana pierce
was totally fine but thank you
dude dude
that's the first time we've made our
goal on twitch actually no way
all right if you if some of you guys are
hanging out that's the best we'll play
another one
that is the absolute best we'll play
another one
you get more sleep the next day
yeah we match donations up to 250. it's
not rules
no champion choose your champion yeah
i know they're going to go back to play
the league oh phoenix drops out
295 it is what it is it is what it is i
i respect it 12 wins in a row you can't
be stopping that train
okay seriously all right
how much was it yeah we can't sleep uh
she did a 2500
donation so now we're at 28 1 2 59.
haley
phoenix getting off it's i love
i love hearing them speak to their
friends i just think that rules
rico's crying dude okay okay i said i
would stop back over about to be the
best
chris i cannot wait i'm gonna go with
congratulations zeke uh
we back over to rico tomorrow uh at 6
p.m
hey 6 p.m pacific time
if i'm off work which i don't i think
i'll still be doing something tomorrow
i don't know how long you guys are going
to be streaming oh probably probably
until like 10 or 11
or 5 hours look at him look how smooth
he got look at that face
guys we uh we went from 150 followers
like an hour or so ago
wait wait wait wait from my uh view
it's our viewers is pretty nice
it is too nice nice nice nice nice nice
nice nice place nice
we went from 150 about an hour ago
we are at 700 that's amazing
i was gonna say 776 but the mustache
does actually suit him you're right rico
looks great
oh yeah you guys want this one thank you
so much
we're at 780 785 followers and i don't
even know how many subs like i'm gonna
i'm gonna pull this is just the best
second
and you guys are just gonna see the
internet for a second while i pull this
out
we have 51 subscribers
oh wow that's more than me that's way
more than me
this man's on top of me we're miles
oh my god
yeah there literally is more than me i
wasn't lying i wasn't mocking them i
don't have subs on twitch
so that that is literally more subs than
me yeah
that was that's for that's for two
thousand i don't know but i have to
downgrade now for the one
ricoh i don't know
this is amazing we'll brainstorm ideas
what what is not affiliated yet
[Laughter]
did you did she just start streaming is
that probably why no i just don't want
to
it's fine oh it doesn't want to be okay
oh i see oh my god so many subs
yeah that that makes so many subs just
blew up right now hang on hang on i'm
gonna do that too
oh my god wow you guys
are my new best friends
[Music]
there you go there you go ah you can't
see it
i just gifted 20 subs
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh the absolute best
[Music]
he i could tell that he'd be crying yeah
you know what uh he's
he's awesome she's so cute i don't
understand i don't understand why but
it's
so weird i spilled water all over myself
oh my gosh okay um
so that that i think we're pretty much
done
uh this is absolutely incredible
um thank you guys so much for joining me
i hope we can go back to the studio
i think breaking rico's has been
wonderful
like multiple people made me cry um
we destroyed a whole bunch of people's
uh charity goals
um and hopefully you guys found some
cool new people to watch as well
um i hope rico is okay
this little gift itself that's amazing
just you love to see it they're so happy
they would just it literally went from
one viewer and it was
me to whatever this is
yeah incredible um yes i will rate them
on twitch
let me set that up
this should be good too i'm gonna watch
it i got how do i where do i get my own
chat from
these chains damn i would love to play
come on here we go okay okay and then
it's like slash raid
and then it's smoking dragons let's go
twitch let's go
let's do it hopefully we can get the
killer in puerto rico
alana is also on uh on youtube right now
hey
okay that's why she's not affiliated
because that way
oh okay okay oh wow 2.4 okay
okay okay okay
and i will send them uh here you go on
on youtube if you want to jump over
there as well
front glitch no you're talking about us
oh
was it the irishman what's happening
what else are we going to do now
i love him so much some people miss the
shavings so
cute oh my gosh it's it's recorded as
our pokemon episode i'm gonna have to
change the title
oh my god okay um thank you all so much
for watching
honestly biggest thanks to tilda five
for doing this this is such a cool thing
to do they're doing a bunch more of them
basically what you have to do is use the
hashtags
clausemycause or tiltify2020 if you're
doing a charity stream and
someone throughout the month of december
may come and do this to your streams
uh it's such a cool idea um
it's like one of the happiest days i've
had all year absolutely amazing they
went from one viewer to almost three
thousand can we get them to three
thousand youtube
because that would be pretty rad if you
guys want to jump over there and that's
when all in the stream
alana herself donated 2 000
for us that is amazing they had one and
it was me
oh my gosh oh it went down no we don't
want that we wanted to go up we wanted
to go up
come on come on can you make me pretty i
don't know anthony
aren't you aren't you aren't you already
pretty i am gorgeous
as hell but i can make you really clear
yes
did it get to 3 000 did it get to three
thousand i don't know i don't know
don't forget to donate for red nose day
oh all of this money that
that we have but regardless i do need to
go to bed
uh donated this was uh such a good time
thank you all so much huge thanks to
tiltify
for putting this together um
my face hurts from smiling so much i
guess i'm gonna have to say let's see i
want to see if there are still people
there
it may have updated better you know
we take 2 500. it's still pretty rat
people do always always leave after
reads that is true
um yeah this is absolutely amazing
uh saw a bunch of cool people and watch
people cry and
look at him look at eureka is gonna
explode rico if you explode oh look at
the kitty
oh my god girl you're on that explosion
i i saw cat and uh
thank you all for watching i'll see you
guys next time bye